[music playing]
I've never been high.
I'm nervous.
I don't know how I'm gonna feel.
See, Mom Aren't you proud?
I've always heard that
edibles are just--
put you on a whole
other type of high.
What are we making?
Today I'm making
kenefeh, which
is filo dough with
ricotta and mozzarella,
and I have mascarpone
and I mix that up.
Right here, you're
gonna see me infuse
with the water soluble THC.
So you see how it is measures
out by the milliliter.
So we're gonna go down,
just one drop basically.
Can I smell that?
Yeah, absolutely.
Do you smell any
cannabis in there?
- I don't.
- Damn right.
When you started
cooking with weed,
was it just because you like to
get high and you like to cook,
so bam?
I was so sick of having the
brownies and the Rice Krispies.
There was no other alternative.
It was brownie or Rice Krispies
from every drug dealer ever,
and they all tasted
like [bleep].
So what I did was start to
put it into, like, puddings
and cakes and stuff
like that and then,
it grew into a more
savory application.
How do you know
what to infuse?
Well, I infuse it based
on what I can control.
Because it all comes
down to proper dosage
because if you get
people too messed up,
it does not fare well for
really anybody involved.
Now, you are about to
do something real big.
We're opening up the
first cannabis-infused
restaurant in the world, yeah.
I know.
The first in the world?
Yeah.
Is that legal?
There's a lot of things,
hurdles that we have to jump.
It's gonna be done and it
should be done by people
that know what they're doing.
I don't know if you've ever
been too high off an edible.
I know you said that
you've never tried any.
Chris, don't do that wink.
For those of you
that have, sometimes it
can be extremely overwhelming.
So we only put it in
certain ingredients
so that we can control it.
If you didn't want
cannabis, we can just
take that ingredient
out and replace
it with a non-infused item.
That way people can enjoy
the experience on their own.
How did you come
up with your name?
I didn't want it to be,
like, Ganga Chef or Weed Chef,
so the Herbal Chef
was kind of natural
and it also is THC,
the acronym, which
is our beloved
tetrahydrocannabinol.
- I'm just gonna take a bite.
- Oh, my god.
It's so good.
Oh!
All right.
So what do you say to
the people who have
never tried an edible before?
We do it in such a way that
it gets you lightly elevated,
so that you're
never overwhelmed.
You don't want to just
dive in right away, right?
You want to dip your toe in.
You want to take your time.
You know, you just ease in.
You can have a long, loving
relationship with cannabis
but you gotta take it slow.
Chris, that is so good.
You like it?
Mm.
Yo.
That's where it's at.
[music playing]